i saw something negative and i said you
know what not today
rachel lindsay is making it clear enough
is enough
i'm honestly exhausted the former
bachelorette star deactivated her
instagram account over the weekend
and on tuesday she revealed on her
podcast higher learning
that the decision came after bachelor
fans would not
stop harassing her in the comments after
this
february interview with franchise host
chris harrison
well rachel is it a good look in 2018 or
is it not a good look in 2021
because there's a big difference ever
because you're she's celebrating the old
south she's so
if i went to that party what would i
represent at that party
chris appeared to defend current
bachelor contestant rachel kercanel
in that interview please stop saying
that i did nothing wrong
that's not true she's under fire for
past racially insensitive actions
including attending an old south
plantation themed party
while in college in 2018. we have to be
so
careful when we start labeling people
after the interview went viral
chris took a step back from the series
and his future with the show
remains up in the air people are
attacking me because they think that i'm
trying to cancel someone so they're on a
mission to cancel me i'm getting
threatened people are threatening like
oh i have this on you i have this i'm
just waiting
so you get back on social to unleash
this kind of stuff i mean it's
you know you're affecting people's
well-being
where does it end where does it stop
like until you take everybody down that
can't be it
the tv host called out the bachelor
franchise for not
speaking out on her behalf amid the
controversy
everyone who's been at issue has issued
an apology except for the franchise
except for the network except for the
production company
you need to hear something from them
they need to come out and say something
they need to
grab a hold of this and control the
situation
because right now you're letting your
fans speak for you
rachel's podcast was seemingly recorded
just hours before
this statement from the show hit the
internet quote
as executive producers of the bachelor
franchise we would like to make it
perfectly clear
that any harassment directed towards
rachel lindsay
in the aftermath of her interview with
chris harrison is completely
unacceptable
in these times right now i feel like we
all are self-reflecting on
have you been an ally what what are you
affiliated with that is part of the
problem you know different you know
you're just you're just looking within
during these times and as i look within
i look at my affiliation with the
bachelor franchise and what's wrong and
i did find it frustrating i don't want
to be affiliated with
a franchise who's not on the right side
of this
at this time at this point you can't be
neutral you're either on the wrong side
or the right side
rachel has yet to respond to the stamp
of support but she does appear to be
distancing herself
from the brand i woke up i looked at my
phone one of the first things
i saw something negative and i said you
know what not today
not even this weekend it was the best
decision
that i could do for myself to detach
from that negativity
i needed that i feel so much better i'm
not 100
but i feel lighter the reality star sat
out of the latest episode of her
bachelor recap podcast
bachelor happy hour where co-host becca
kufrin
shared that she stands by rachel taking
a break she
has been taking on so much in the world
of bachelor nation and i want to
extend my support and friendship and
just give her
a little break
you